I think unfortunately America the world
has fallen in love with pointing fingers
and what I say to people is find your
thumb point it to yourself and realize
that you're actually in control of your
outcome you can blame all sorts of other
scenarios but once you realize you're in
control you can put in the hard work you
can change your perspective then you can
get your outcome
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right Vlog I have no idea why I did
this this morning it actually reminds me
of like just hard work consistency right
we're going to do this 620 hit I had to
get up at like 5 a.m it's freezing here
don't let Arizona confuse you the desert
gets cold in the morning and night you
know like for this two three minutes on
Fox News to talk about Super Bowl
commercials you know you get four hours
less of sleep and I'm you know I think a
lot of you know this I'm big on sleep
seven eight hours one person could watch
this show this morning from a marketing
standpoint that brings an opportunity
for vaynermedia and that's the work you
have to be putting in and you know the
reality is I've been grinding and I'm at
a pretty good place in my career but a
lot of people won't do this and so I
will and so that's that
it's the actual game uh Gary they expect
208 million people to be watching this
game that's it yeah
how many people debate whether this is
pays off does it pay so Vayner over the
last four years vaynermedia the company
I run has had 11 12 spots in this big
game and this year we've got two for
Pepsi which is huge Pepsi Zero and we've
got Mr Peanut coming back with Planters
you know a couple years ago we killed
them off right we resurrected them we've
got a big roast still reality is those
30 seconds with as many people that are
watching is actually worth it in
comparison to all other commercials I do
think it's the best ad the 7 million the
problem is is the video in 30 seconds
good you don't let anything stand in
your way what advice you have people who
are saying themselves uh I'm gonna get
myself a kid unfortunately America the
world has fallen in love with pointing
fingers and what I say to people is find
your thumb point it to yourself and
realize that you're actually in control
of your outcome you can blame all sorts
of other scenarios but once you realize
you're in control you can put in the
hard work you can change your
perspective then you can get your
outcome when you look at your life what
are you proudest of the money the
notoriety
what what gives you most gratification
making my parents proud you know my
parents were born in the USSR and lived
their entire childhood and into their
early adult life in a country that had
no opportunity and they took the chance
to come to this great country and
there's nothing better than being the
firstborn of an immigrant family and
executing to make them proud and I think
that that's a heck of a lot more
interesting than than the the dollar
bills and the notoriety
[Music]